[Music]
we can all learn some lessons about
health care from a former professional
athlete who had a serious accident
and ended up in intensive care cyclist
phil geiman
was left on the hook for about a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in medical
bills
even though he had double health
insurance he crashed during an olympic
qualifying race in 2019
we're examining unexpected medical costs
as part of our continuing bill of the
month
series in partnership with kaiser health
news and npr
phil guyman's qualifying olympic race
ended with a crash
when he collided with another cyclist he
was thrown
from his bike at about 40 miles an hour
breaking
seven bones guyman was rushed
unconscious to a nearby er room
at lehigh valley hospital in allentown
pennsylvania
so when i woke up it was uh it was
excruciating pain i'd broken
all the ribs on my right side my
collarbone
and my my scapula my shoulder blade
guyman received collarbone surgery at
lehigh valley
and a second procedure on his shoulder
bone at the hospital
for special surgery in new york both the
surgeries were completely necessary
i was just in tremendous pain all around
he made a quick recovery at home but
then the bills came
they totaled over two hundred thousand
dollars from both hospitals
his two insurances paid a total of only
fifty two thousand dollars
leaving him on the hook for about a
hundred and fifty thousand
he realized lehigh valley hospital was
out of network
and his scapula surgery was classified
as an elective procedure
instead of an emergency which could have
saved him money
they they hit you with the bills when
you're literally least capable of
handling anything
i get a stack of bills every month i get
collections notices every day
guyman has spent months calling and
writing letters to his primary insurance
healthnet to persuade them to cover more
of the bills
but he's been unsuccessful healthnet
said that it's committed to providing
high quality care with a large
choice of in-network providers and that
members should contact them
for assistance this could happen to
anybody at any time um
where you could just wake up in a
hospital and then later find out you owe
them 150
000 i wish i knew that getting health
insurance was still essentially a gamble
lehigh valley health network told kaiser
health news that they have no record of
guymon trying to contact them about
financial assistance
and that they would be happy to discuss
a mutual resolution of his outstanding
balance
the hospital for special surgery said
they reached out to guymon to help
resolve the dispute about the surgery
classification and will continue to
advocate on his behalf
joining us now is dr elizabeth rosenthal
the editor-in-chief
of kaiser health news dr rosenal thanks
so much for being with us how common are
some of the issues
that phil experienced well as
as we know at bill of the month billing
hospital billing is filled with land
mines and
phil hit three of them out of network
hospitals
high costs and here's the biggie in his
case
insurance from one state often doesn't
work very well in another
so what so what are your tips for an
emergency situation like this
well what happened to phil is he got hit
with something called
balance billing and it's a type of
surprise bill
you go to a hospital that's out of
network
and according to all the surprise
billing laws that many states have
you're only supposed to be charged in an
emergency what you would have been
charged
at an in-network hospital so phil's
insurer which was california based
paid what it considered a reasonable
rate
the hospital wants both hospitals wanted
far more
and they balance build phil for the
difference
if he'd been in california which has a
good surprise billing law
that would have been illegal but because
he was in pennsylvania
and new york and insurance is state
regulated
they could do it there are new federal
perspectives
sorry go ahead yeah so there are
some things you could do of course phil
was unconscious so you know you're not
in a place to be a
savvy healthcare consumer but if you are
still awake you can ask
to go to a hospital that's in network
when they
ask you to sign those forms that say
i'll pay for anything my insurance
doesn't cover you can
add in as long as it's in my network and
you have a choice if an ambulance comes
to pick you up
and you don't think you need an
ambulance you can say i'm not getting in
yeah well that's a tough choice to make
dr elizabeth rosenthal thank you very
much
we'll be right back